As soon as it happened the media...
Oh, it's because of the music.
Today, rap music has come under fire in some
quarters. Run DMC says it preaches positive
messages, yet its tour has been marred by
violence. Today, the group held a news
conference to say none of this was its
fault.
We don't think our music and concert inspires
this kind of behavior.
Stuff like this been happening since the
dawn of time.
Listen to run DMC, you won't find nothing
that incites or promotes what happened at
the L.A. Coliseum.
We were trying to introduce to hip hop
culture that could save and transform your
communities and your individual being.
L.A. wasn't ready for that sh*t.
At that time, I sniffed.
That there was a seat change.
So NWA was our opening act and they were
bringing the heat.
That heat was hot.
And I walked in to our dressing room and
said, "Houston,
we have a problem." What's cracking.
It's your homeboy, Ice cube.
West coast warlord.
Grand wizard.
Self-made. Cool-Aid.
My first record I ever bought with my own
money was the first Run-DMC album.
I think the record cost $7.99, and I had
about $3 $4 and my man had about $4, and we
bought the album.
It would be at my house for four days and at
his house for three days.
I'm telling you, like clockwork, when it was
my turn. Boom boom boom boom.
Give me the record, man.
To me, run was the dopest MC on the planet.
It's like Run D.M.C.
saying, what the hell they want to say.
Why we can't. And so when it was our turn,
we did what we was supposed to do.
We gave him the blueprint attitude, how to
rock those mics and make those beats.
Then they started taking specific aspects of
socio economical, cultural, political trauma
and addressed it in a way that was bold
faced.
When I started to get into rap, I wanted to
rap like Run-DMC.
I wanted to rap like New York rappers.
My boys were saying, say that other sh*t
talking about these criminal rhymes that I
would say. It was like, oh, y'all want to
hear this sh*t? This is what I do.
Press said, it's gangster rap.
Gangsta rap, the rap style of a ghetto world
where everybody's got a gun.
Women are b*tches and shooting cops is fair
game.